hi Hulu fans you're here with Caleb
worthy and Krista marieu from Hulu's new
original series reboots so if you love
sitcoms revivals and revivals of
fictional sitcoms our new series is the
one for you make sure to check it out
and stick around to see what else is
coming to Hulu this month
beautiful
isn't it
it's really nice
you can hold it
it's time
greater Delights await
their blood all for us
praise the Lord
your mother she's very popular in the
village
mom I've missed that word
save again
what's happening to me there's something
going around
some scary internet character that tells
you to kill people it made this kid stab
his own mother you saw the Grim Cuddy
yeah like in my house oh what is it
something about today feels special hell
yeah this is gonna be scary
I always hate this spooky ass month
especially Halloween it's too haunting
and spine tingling
the greatest love story ever told Romeo
sweet Juliet was missing a chapter
mine Sonoma
I am a bit overwhelmed right now I'm
trying to be a good friend and a good
mother clearly I'm not being a good wife
it's just a child separation Jax I
didn't get married to sleep alone
it's been a long time I hear you're
planning to admit to a crime you didn't
commit you'll be saying you're a
criminal I thought you liked criminals
we are doing such amazing things as a
family
this whole ride has been a roller
coaster
welcome to season two making world-class
food in the wild that's a challenge dude
you're killing
oh
three two now we're gonna let the food
do the talking Romy has been searching
for something
trying to find the meaning of life
he is in debt you owe them one hundred
thousand dollars not just about the
money
he's in spiritual debt you're in
spiritual debt you're out you're asking
for my like if it's spiritual then can
we just not charge so much
are you not a Democrat
well I'm not a Democrat you kids you can
be six of different genders but you have
to fit into the Democrats I'm
politically fluid
I feel a different kind of Prisons
an evil one
what's going on we've found a part of a
man in the woods today
it's got to be an animal right
I'm
Annie Hardy and you're watching band car
Another Day in Paradise
I need a research assistant
she's one of the best investigators I
had but she's different in what way in
every way I must have alarmed you
turning up if you touch me I'll more
than alarm you
you're born reporter you're one of the
best why are you here Stanley to offer
you a job Cold Case in Alaska she went
missing two years ago her death is part
of a pattern a murdered indigenous women
someone reporter you don't need me you
break big stories only we're just
missing too much
Alaska doesn't need another corrupt
reporters spewing lies go back to New
York before something bad happens
he said you won't have any trouble being
detained
agents looked at me and said we got you
I see something in them
the spark yeah the drive the genius
the next person that walks down on this
beach could be my future husband cheers
it's getting messy on this beach
it's a monster of a new season the
20-somethings these old geezers better
learn versus the 40-somethings this old
guy's here to play who goes down in
frames call Weddington and pink chicken
you think I'm gonna serve that it's an
elite singer of Kiss get out you can't
always wait for people to flock you
sometimes you just have to flock
yourself
[Music]
Barb Fletch I haven't seen you since
Girl Scout camp and you type me to my
phone good memories
wonder what's in it
it's really heavy it has to be like
three four hundred pounds seriously oh
singer is back and it has more
performances every episode more stars
more new costumes plus two celebrity
unmaskings every week I got so excited I
had to take my jacket off
foreign
[Music]
[Music]